welcome to this video this is PF lit
coping that's a nemo club or something
okie dokie John King xinya playing a bit
of the classical lately and we have okay
in 97 that seven the somewhat
old-fashioned move but not so bad yeah
all night age five interesting sideline
i recently got that in the Blitz game I
remember correctly okay so he allows me
my ideal setup interestingly enough so a
34 before
yeah the way he played that is very sure
let's say it he's absolutely not trying
to challenge me there on the queenside
or just very obliging
so let's check queen bee 345 one rupee
one is also pretty good movie once it
grabbed c5 directly given that's
interesting
no not sure not sure yeah this is lost
night g-force was why I was a little bit
hesitant but well my g4 it's not a not a
big problem
yeah very quick on the queenside while
he's not even close to f5 I mean okay he
can play a 5 but i have f 3 and this
makes it look quite ridiculous okay we
know that already the opponent playing
some move that I call unplayable and
this is unplayable ready where's it
going my next will be c6 and that's it
check problem is this night on a six
that said it's a trap piece I play
Quincy for and pick up the night that's
all it's not the first time let's say
that this happens and chairs Quincy for
I am just a to look again I mean you can
take Queen takes and then be five it's
also quite quite terrible
it is a piece um I can't do I have
something better Luke a six and takes
here okay let's take that that's good
enough
check
black resins and this is this kind of
thing is quite quite well known and just
clearly better for white I mean the
crucial point is that here here like has
to do something against white getting 92
in if I get this and I have the ideal
setup in the classical those two bishops
and nights on d 2 and C 3 this is
actually the the best possible set up
the reason is that i'm ready for a 3 i
have the bishop here but a difference to
go to the main line with night III d3b
should be three set my night is not only
one but here so it can jump to see for
all the time and he in fact he has
played this mookie aid the system
doesn't make any sense in connection to
what he did if he wants to make sense of
the line and he can actually has to go
night h5 this is it this is quite
interesting it intends to put this night
damn and i'm going g3 now preventing
that info and then the hunky move Bishop
f6 the ideas night back Bishop e7 and f5
this looks a bit strange but it has been
played by a job offer and other experts
of the Kings Indian and so that is ok
and here it's already very difficult for
like I get this in and it um it's just a
very quick attack see if I I'm already
threatening cystic I think this is
already probably beyond saving I don't
see how he saves that the night years
offside it cannot move it's basically a
pin and something like that I can it can
play this probably again normally you
can in this kind of situation okay I can
lot I actually cannot maybe because he
has this trick this is hanging
Jiggs may okay that's it's not the
clearest way possible but you can after
sorry c5 if he goes back instead I have
an ID see forces probably the way to go
also intending possible Knight a5 you
know I'm compass on hours plus two if
you give it some time just winning on
the queenside yeah and this man this
didn't help but it doesn't drag doesn't
really matter yeah b5 is also good it
has no square that also is a winning
line but this is enough and I don't
think here there was anything Jack
happening in particular job and resins
just picking up this the rest of the
rest of the pawns yeah black index
indian classical he has to prevent the
setup if you look through all of the
lines this is the set up that black has
to avoid because it's really good night
on evolve bishop only three is a
different story but with a 92 it's much
much better for what okay thanks for
watching